i think i've been very happy everybody
says man you just seem like you're in a
better mood this offseason i said you're
damn right i am
so this guy he's a special guy i think
uh one of the best ways that i can
describe him when you hear people that
have been around him there's a there's a
known confidence where when he walks
into a room you always feel his presence
but he's got a great humility about
himself
that everybody loves being around him
and he's one of those guys that i think
is a true igniter makes everybody around
him better i feel like i've become a
better coach in the few months that
we've been able to spend together and
we're looking forward to doing a lot of
good things together i hate that i even
have to say this but i think i made a
comment earlier that was definitely
taken out of context i am very excited i
have been in a good mood because of the
confidence i have in this team but by no
means is that a slight to anybody you
know like jared who has done a
phenomenal job for the last four years
here i hated that i even have to address
that but i do think out of respect for
him and all the good things he's done i
am in a good mood but that doesn't mean
it's not because we're working together
uh or because of just stafford
exclusively there's a lot of good things
going on that i feel really good about
and i'm confident about so don't twist
my words
when i didn't say that
oh god help me come on sean mcveigh come
on
come on what are you gonna believe what
are you gonna believe what are you going
to believe what are you going to believe
you're going to believe
the loose and relaxed sean mcvay where
the truth escapes his vocal cords or
you're going to believe the hostage
video which one are you going to believe
miles
listen i spent as we know a lot of time
covering sean mcvay man and like
whenever he uses the tone when he brings
it out like this you know he don't twist
my words like he used the same tone when
he was talking about matthew stafford
you're damn right i'm in a better mood
everybody tells me hey you look like
you're in a better mood man like yeah
you're damn right like come on like it's
not when i first saw that video i first
saw the comments and i i said it to a
couple buddies of mine i'm like
wait a minute like what's he doing here
like can he help himself and then the
same thing when i saw the video i'm like
this is worse like if you're jared goff
and you see that you're like
come on man like why you got to do
something like that and it's not really
taking his words out of context it's
really frankly not
people think that
if you take a quote
out of a broader comment
you've taken it out of context not if
that quote meshes with the meaning of
the broader
statement there
there's nothing in what he said that was
out of context it was accurate it was
his feelings and you know i i i'm even
more miffed that sean mcvay would do
this than a player it's one thing for a
player to do because a player is not
there to be a wordsmith coaches are
communicators you got to be able to make
your point and if you make your point in
a clumsy way that comes off as a slap
at the guy who was the quarterback when
you weren't in a good mood
if you do that that's on you as a coach
you've failed to communicate don't blame
anyone else don't blame us
that's on you apologize to jared goff
don't blame the media for taking the
comment out of context you're going to
lose me there immediately when you try
to play those games because we're not
dumb
coach you may think we're dumb you may
think it's enough just to say our name
when you're given the answer and we're
going to be won over that's not how this
game works bro you got to be straight
with us you got to be honest with us and
that that hostage video from yesterday i
look at that and i say you know what he
really is john gruden miles
oh yeah and i don't mean that in a good
way
i don't mean that i know
but i knew that you didn't mean it in a
good way maybe the audience did look i i
think it's interesting because like
there was a period of time where sean
mcvay was extremely linked to jared goff
and he wanted it that way i mean that
was something that he talked about in
the summer of 2019 when he got his
contract extension he said he wanted to
be tied to jared goff you know for as
long as those two were to for as long as
he was there you know as a coach right
like that was his thing and so
we all know that that relationship
crumbled over the last two years in part
because jared goff couldn't stop turning
the ball over right that was something
that he talked about in the season our
quarterback has to take better care of
the football then after that playoff
loss in green bay jared goff is our
quarterback right now you know you get
less sneed saying he's our quarterback
for this moment and then jared goff is
gone and then you bring in matthew
stafford because you believe that's the
guy who can help you win the super bowl
so you can play it off as if you're
saying yes i'm in a better mood because
this guy's my quarterback but the
question that he got asked there was
basically what do you think of matthew
stafford and then you're saying you know
everybody says you look like you're in a
better mood there's only one way to
interpret that quote like it's not that
it's taken out of context we have we
have the larger context because
everybody knows what happened so there's
only one way to interpret it and i know
that like you don't want it to be
interpreted that way and it might not
have you might not have even thought
that that's where you were going with it
as it came out of your mouth but
as people who know the entire context of
what this is when you say something like
that there's only one way to interpret
it and that's the way we have to go with
it i just i don't know what else to say
almost two years ago to the day what is
today today's the eleventh two years ago
to the day posted this at pft quote from
sean mcvay any of the things or
narratives that are out there jared goff
as long as i'm fortunate enough to be in
this role hopefully this guy's stuck
with me for a long time
i was an outstanding leader
people make a deal about the system he's
the reason why our players are the
reason why the system is what it is
because he can do so many different
things and really when you just look at
the confidence we have in him taking
steps from year one in the system to
year two and just thinking back last
year how confident he was and now i
think it's even that much more this year
he's got true ownership great ability to
communicate with his teammates yada yada
that was two years ago today and uh
uh yeah you're in a better mood now that
he's gone
it's fine it's fine
why why
why are you afraid to admit the obvious
and and you're right miles when you're
asked about matthew stafford and you're
the head coach and you lead it that way
again this gets back to the ability to
communicate or not that a coach truly
has he took it there don't blame us
when you took it there that's the bottom
line as i see it miles
yeah you know and you can't blame the
media for interpreting your words as
something like the way that they were
interpreted i just because like i said
we all know what happened we all know
that he was very disappointed in what
jared goff had been putting out there
the last two years so if you're in a
better mood because matthew stafford's
your quarterback yeah you should be in a
better mood i mean like i would probably
be in a better mood too if i thought
that i was my team was a quarterback
away and then we went out and then we
got that quarterback that i think is
going to not just take us to the playoff
level help us win a playoff game but and
get our our scoring level back to the
top two top three level that it was in
2017 and 2018 before you know everybody
seemed to figure jared goff out and what
defenses he could or could not read or
what throws he was or wasn't capable of
making
yeah like if you think you can unlock
everything that you've ever wanted to be
as an offense as a head coach and as a
play caller yes you should be in a
better mood but
you can't blame us for interpreting
things based on the facts that we all
have in front of us
that's the only conclusion that i can
come to here
i i got another trip down memory lane
for you this is bringing back all sorts
of stuff from a couple of years ago and
i've been vindicated so i'm i'm even
happier to share this with you
thank you
that i was wrong
listen because i reacted miles to the
quotes from sean mcvay which were made
before jared goff got his second
contract i know by saying these things
you're driving up his price his agent is
going to print it off laminate it and
slap it down on the table when it's time
to negotiate you're saying all these
great that's one of the first things i
learned in this business getting to know
general managers executives coaches you
don't praise your guy publicly until
after he gets his contract because
they're going to jam it down your throat
when you do so fred rogan who was with
the nbcla affiliate time i frankly don't
know if he still is
uh i guess he is okay he called me out
for saying they shouldn't pay jared goff
they shouldn't pay jared goff they
should wait and see he's got three years
in two years left missed a championship
throw in the super bowl it's mcveigh's
system why are you going to pay him 35
million a year it doesn't make any sense
to me here's rogan to goff
two years ago tomorrow
i don't know how often you check online
and care what the pundits say one of
them
suggested that the thing about jared
goff is there will be a point in time
we're just going to get rid of him
because you're going to bring somebody
in who's younger who will be your kind
of guy now to me i thought that was
insane because you've developed goff
into one of the top quarterbacks in the
game that was two years ago tomorrow and
you know what he did bring somebody else
in and he had to tuck a first-round pick
into the trade package on top of the one
and a three to get rid of goff's
contract and i still think they did that
mile so staying cronky wouldn't realize
they had to give up a first round pick
to get rid of jared goff
well the only thing you kind of got
wrong there was that they were bringing
somebody younger they actually brought
in somebody older and i'll take i'll
take anybody at this point
joe namath at this point over jared goff
well i mean they got somebody who they
thought could elevate the offense but i
look i remember when you were writing
that stuff because at the time i was
still working there and i'm thinking man
this guy mike florio you shouldn't read
that crap from that guy because
you know
he doesn't know anything he's not here
your wildest dreams or nightmares would
you actually be working with me i know
one more look where i am today two years
later man and look who was right because
it was just funny because i look the
thing about sometimes that what we can
do that other people who are in it every
day can't do you see it from this 30 000
foot view right
and if you're in it every day and you
feel like well they love jared goff
jared goff has performed to this level
he's done this he's done that they just
went to the super bowl you don't
necessarily see it from the league
perspective where it's like well there
are probably a bunch of guys around the
league who are playing like jared goff
is playing and could maybe play better
in this system and that is clearly the
conclusion that the rams themselves have
come to over the last couple of years
that jared goff is not elevating this
thing enough
so that you know you can justify paying
him what they're paying him what they
were paying him and now detroit's
partially paying no so you know
when you go out and you get matthew
stafford like
yeah it's vindication for you for those
things that you wrote two years ago but
it's also you're admitting basically
that you made a mistake
in paying jared goff what you paid him
and giving him that contract and so all
these things now from two years ago it's
like man
you know florio i guess was right and
maybe you should read that crap because
you might learn something for later
that is the best endorsement we've ever
gotten and look here's the thing i don't
need to pick on sean mcvay but but don't
don't don't listen there's a price to be
paid when you play that game with the
media never pick a fight with someone
who buys their ink by the truckload
don't blame us for the thing you said
you said it own it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports